alors comment ça va depuis
hier le silence devient difficile pour
d'autres raisons depuis le début c'est
parce queon a envie d'échanger avec les
autres on a envie de leur poser des
questions on a envie d'échanger et nous
on sait pas très bien faire ça en
silence parce que on n pas l'habitude on
est je veux dire on est tous des gens
voilà qui qui communiquent beaucoup des
gens de la télé et cetera donc on sait
pas faire et Paul je l'ai vu souffrir
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que quand j'ai vu
sa détresse à vouloir vraiment vous
parler du coup ça me fait me poser des
questions sur
l'efficacité pardon de cette technique
qui est si éloignée de de la NRE c'est
intéressant ce que vous venez de dire
j'ai deux trois pensées je vous les
donne en vraque comme ça la première
vous avez utilisé le on oui moi je pense
que vous pouvez utiliser que le jeu
parce qu'en fait pour vous c'est
difficile à titre personnel oui c'estè